Die „Golden Gate Bridge
vom Niederrhein“ in Deutschland.
Verblüffend die Ähnlichkeit zum Original im
US-amerikanischen San Francisco.
Autor Christoph Karrasch macht
während der Corona-Pandemie
eine Weltreise durch Deutschland:
Island und Japan trennen
hier nur gut einhundert Kilometer,
und es ist auch nicht weit bis zur Südsee.
Großes Fernweh,
das war die Hauptmotivation.
Ich wollte gerne wieder reisen und unterwegs
sein, aber es ging natürlich eben einfach nicht
im Ausland
oder schon gar nicht
auf anderen Kontinenten.
Und dann bin ich darüber gestolpert,
dass es Orte gibt,
die so heißen wie andere Orte:
Kalifornien und Brasilien
und Amerika, Russland und Rom.
All diese Orte gibt es wirklich in Deutschland.
Andernach am Rhein: eine der ältesten
Städte Deutschlands.
Die Römerstadt im Bundesland
Rheinland-Pfalz ist der Ausgangspunkt
für Christoph Karraschs
Abstecher nach Island.
Drei Wochen lang hat er für
sein Buch „San Francisco liegt am Rhein“
die große weite Welt entdeckt –
innerhalb der Grenzen Deutschlands.
Nach fünfzehn Minuten Bootsfahrt
erreicht er das Ziel,
den höchsten Kaltwassergeysir der Welt.
Geysir ist Isländisch
und bedeutet „ausbrechen“.
Da geht‘s gleich los!
Der rostbraune Haufen!
Das ist heute übrigens auch wieder der erste
Ausbruch des Tages, und da
faucht‘s gleich so richtig doll los,
weil es sich quasi…. da!...
aus der Nacht erst mal entladen muss.
So, Achtung! Und jetzt geht‘s los.
Ich weiß nicht,
ob‘s schon 50 Meter sind, aber…
Ich war selber auch schon mal auf Island
und hab‘ da zwei Wochen lang
leider nur Regenwetter mitbekommen.
Deswegen ist das für mich sozusagen gerade
rein wettermäßig das Paradies.
Und ja, es ist so ein Islandquickie.
Es ist ein kurzes Einstippen
in eine ganz faszinierende Natur,
die da auf Island herrscht und die man hier
eben nachempfinden und nacherleben kann.
Der nächste Stopp
auf seiner „Weltreise“ ist Japan.
Die Rheinmetropole Düsseldorf:
Dieses Stadtviertel im Zentrum
trägt den Namen „Little Tokyo“.
Düsseldorf beheimatet die drittgrößte
japanische Gemeinde Europas
nach London und Paris.
Hier findet sich fast alles,
was das japanische Herz begehrt.
Wie Buchläden mit einem
rein japanischen Sortiment,
mit dem Christoph Karrasch
jedoch nur wenig anfangen kann.
Anders die japanische Bäckerei um die Ecke.
Hier gibt es ostasiatische Klassiker.
Das gute grüne Zeug: Matcha Pan.
Die Gebäckspezialitäten sind
nicht wie in Deutschland kross,
sondern weich gebacken
und in Plastikfolie eingepackt
– auch das ist ganz authentisch japanisch,
ebenso wie der Geschmack.
Okay.
Mmhhh, das ist gefüllt!
Im Vergleich zu vielen anderen Orten,
die ich auf dieser Weltreise durch
Deutschland besucht hab',
ist das hier die echte große weite Welt
plötzlich mitten in Deutschland.
Das finde ich ganz faszinierend.
Viele andere Orte spielen ja eher so mit dem
Klischee, quasi mit den großen Namen,
und hier ist es aber wirklich so.
Du kannst für ein paar Stunden einfach
abtauchen in so was wie ‘nem kleinen Japan.
Ja, deswegen passt der Name auch
– Little Tokyo. Total.
Von Japan geht es entlang des Rheins mit
einem Zwischenstopp in der Südsee –
einem künstlich geschaffenen
Badesee bei Xanten –
zurück in die USA nach San Francisco.
Die echte Route misst mehr als 15.000
Kilometer,
in Deutschland sind es rund einhundert.
Die Golden Gate Bridge vom Niederrhein.
Das Ziel: Deutschlands längste Hängebrücke,
803 Meter lang,
gelegen zwischen Kleve und Emmerich
nahe der niederländischen Grenze.
Das Original ist mehr als dreimal so lang.
Doch für Christoph Karrasch ist die kleine
deutsche Kopie eine echte Entdeckung.
Es gibt keine Geheimtipps mehr
in Deutschland, denkt man oft.
Aber wenn man die Perspektive mal ändert
und ja, zum Beispiel versucht,
eine Weltreise im eigenen Land zu machen,
dann sieht man neue Orte, von denen man
vorher noch nie gehört hat.
Ich wusste nicht, dass so eine Brücke
in Deutschland existiert.
Deutschland –
ein Land, das weit mehr Abwechslung bietet,
als man glaubt.